Namotasa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudasa Namotasa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudasa Namotasa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudasa
homage to the Buddha the blessed noble and fully self-enlightened one just looking at this word dukkha so it's not new to the Buddha it was fairly you know common coinage really goes back a long way in the
in the spiritual-religious history of India.
And the word is actually made up of two parts, dukkha, which just means a hard place.
I don't think anybody would dispute that being a human being on this earth is a hard place.
Even in our own mythology, Adam and Eve get chucked out of the garden, have to start working and come across sickness, old age and death.
So he starts off with that, I mean that's what really drives him to seek spiritual, or to join the spiritual life of his time, because this dukkha, and it's in the air, it's in the air of his society, it's a society which is dislocated because there's a lot of political change going on, moving from the old
pastoral more democratic societies to monarchical and big cities were arriving and wars were getting worse so in that sort of dislocation of time people tend to seek some sort of spiritual relief
and we can say that around about the age of middle 20 which I think is fairly common there's a sort of awakening up to the fact that youth has come to an end or is coming to an end and one looks forward to sickness old age and death so with that there comes a sort of crisis in him these days I suppose we call it an existential crisis
and off he goes on his search and eventually through his awakening he discerns three types of dukkha the first one is called dukkha dukkha
Which translates to just ordinary miserable suffering.
So if you say to somebody, do you suffer?
They say, they don't suffer.
Well, there's something wrong with them.
Because everybody has some form of suffering.
But even though physical pain is...
sort of included in that it's not really included in the end of suffering because physical pain is part of our nature it's not something that the liberation gets rid of the Buddha himself as you know died of some form of gastroenteritis which was rather unpleasant so it's not as though he got rid of physical pain
So this dukkha dukkha really refers to the emotional stuff that we go through.
But it also includes the pain that comes from indulgence, from getting attached to things.
And the second one is viparināma-dukkha, which is the dukkha, the suffering we feel when we come across transience, when we come across impermanence.
Whenever we get to a place where we feel comfortable, the right job, right relationship and all that sort of stuff, there's always this sort of clinging to it, sort of holding it, and it makes us blind to the fact that it's changing, it's in a process of flux.
and so not being aware of that we tend not to want to change things that are pleasant for us on the other hand we crave for things to change when they're not right when we're in a rotten situation when the job goes wrong when the relationship goes awry and when the body starts messing us about then we get this desire to escape from it
So we're always working against the sort of present moment, the self, this position we take towards life.
It's always about trying to find happiness within this situation, within the sensual world, within the thought world, within the heart world.
and therefore in doing that we find ourselves always in conflict there's always a subtle conflict about going on either we want to get rid of something or we want to hold on to it and then there's a more subtle suffering that comes that's known as Sankata Dukkha and that's a suffering that comes from the delusion of being a self
And what we mean by that is that we experience ourselves as an integer, as something fairly solid, as the agent, as the person in control.
I do my own thing in my own way, my own time, a self-made person.
And this idea of a self obviously comes across certain problems.
So, like the body, we know intellectually that the body isn't me and not mine because it dies.
We've got plenty of proof of that.
Even so, when something goes wrong with the body, then we get really upset, and if something really terrible goes wrong with the body, it's a real shock, it's a problem for us, and death itself is still a horrible thing, even though intellectually we know these things are going to happen.
So that peculiar way that we relate to the body, of identifying with it, even though we say we don't, and of somehow possessing it, you know, we have a language such as, you know, I have a big nose, see?
I have big ears, I have got big ears, but I am sick, the body is sick, but I am sick, but I have a headache.
It's sort of a dualistic relationship that we have to this body.
And of course the sudden realization that we don't control the body in any real sense
We can't stop it growing old, we can't stop it falling sick and so on.
This brings a lot of fear and that fear is the undermining of the idea that the body is me and mine.
And it's the same without emotions.
You don't go to bed making a determination to wake up depressed.
You just wake up depressed.
And it's these sorts of recognitions that there are things going on inside us, both at the physical and mental level, over which we don't have this control.
And it's these sorts of little insights that begin to undermine this idea of, well, who am I?
Who am I?
So these three qualities that the Buddha called dukkha turn out to be really the three characteristics of existence, which is the sense of impermanence, the unsatisfactory nature that we can never really find real deep contentment,
by seeking happiness in the world, if only because it arises and passes away.
And this sort of deeper delusion about who we are, or what we are,
So that's really a sort of definition of dukkha according to the Buddha.
And this term is at the root of his teaching.
He actually says that all he teaches is dukkha, dukkha nirodha, suffering and satisfaction that's in the end of it.
It's in three words in the Pali.
So it's something that he builds the whole of his teaching on.
And the Four Noble Truths are centered on that dukkha.
It's the fact of suffering, the cause of suffering, the end of suffering, and the path leading to the end of suffering.
So it's something to...
To just contemplate.
Now, when we're in our meditation, you see, we can normally see these things so, you know, to a point we can see it fairly clearly.
But it's really taking that out into our daily practice where it has, you know, good effect.
Simple things like recognizing little attachments to cups of tea and TV programs and just seeing how actually that can cause a lot of suffering.
You know, a TV breaking down when you want to watch a football match, things like that, horrible things.
So it's sort of recognizing that when somebody comes to you and they say something and you feel irritation or disappointment, where's that coming from?
And it's awakening to the fact that the suffering that we're actually experiencing is all self-created.
and that puts you in charge that makes you responsible for your own mental states and what the Buddha is saying is that once you take full responsibility for your mental states for your unsatisfactoriness for your suffering then that's the path out of it because then you'll try and do something about it rather than blame the world blame society blame this and blame that
So it's really contemplating this whole area of dukkha and how we create suffering for ourselves and taking it into our daily lives which is the practice.
So my usual hope is that my words are of some assistance and that you are fully liberated from all suffering sooner.